This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1928, a strange phenomenon was sweeping the state of Idaho, a vanishing act of sorts. A Boise resident would wake up on a typical Monday morning, drag themselves out of bed, get dressed for the day, and they would hop in their car to drive to work, not noticing that something was missing. And suddenly, cops in the rear view. And the next thing that the driver of the car knew, they were getting picked up because they weren't displaying a... license plate. Idaho historian Rick Just says license plates, well, they were disappearing. The Secretary of State was fielding complaints about all the lost tags. And soon enough, the culprit became clear. Tourists would come to Idaho and steal the plates.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1928年，爱达荷州正在席卷一股奇怪的现象，某种程度上的消失行为。一个博伊西居民在一个平常的周一早晨醒来，把自己从床上拖起来，穿好衣服准备出门，他们会跳上车去上班，却没有注意到有什么东西不见了。突然间，后视镜里出现了警察。车里的司机接下来意识到的事情是，他们被拦下了，因为他们没有悬挂……车牌。爱达荷州历史学家里克·贾斯特说，车牌，嗯，它们正在消失。州务卿不断接到关于所有丢失车牌的投诉。不久之后，罪魁祸首就水落石出了。游客来到爱达荷州，偷走了这些车牌。
Idaho's license plates were being snatched up like plush hotel bathrobes. Yeah, yeah. People would come up, but they would pull up to either a tourist park or a motel or something, and they would spot those plates and think, you know, I'd like to have a souvenir. and so they would just take it off of the car and take it home. And there was a reason why people couldn't resist swiping Idaho plates in particular. That year, the state had revolutionized license plate design. That's reporter Daniel Ackerman. Before this, plates were basic, with info like the state name and the registration numbers.
爱达荷州的车牌就像高档酒店的浴袍一样被抢走。是的，是的。人们会开车过来，把车停在旅游公园、汽车旅馆或类似的地方，然后他们会盯上那些车牌，心想，你知道的，我想要个纪念品。于是他们就会把车牌从车上卸下来带回家。人们对爱达荷州的车牌尤其无法抗拒，这是有原因的。那一年，该州彻底革新了车牌设计。那是记者丹尼尔·阿克曼。在此之前，车牌都很基础，上面只有州名和注册号等信息。
All of this on a pretty simple, solid colored background. But in 1928, the Secretary of State in Idaho, had an epiphany. He was like, we have this half square foot of open real estate just rolling around on everyone's cars. Let's do something with it. The 1928 plate is often said to be the very first advertising license plate in the country. They're the very first one that tried to advertise a product. And the product that Idaho chose will surprise absolutely no one. The state's 1928 license plates all featured a single giant potato. A big kind of elongated, goofy-looking potato. The state of but big. It was almost as big as the plate.
所有这些都在一个相当简单、纯色的背景上。但在1928年，爱达荷州务卿突然有了一个顿悟。他当时想，我们每个人的车上都有这半平方英尺的空白地产在闲置。我们用它做点什么吧。1928年的车牌通常被认为是全国第一个广告车牌。它们是第一个试图宣传产品的车牌。而爱达荷州选择的产品绝对会让所有人大吃一惊。该州1928年的所有车牌上都印着一个巨大的土豆。一个很大、有点呈椭圆形、滑稽的土豆。这个州的——但很大。它几乎和车牌一样大。
The registration numbers were stamped in green lettering right on top of this lumpy brown spud. I would say it looks almost fecal in nature. It does. The shape, particularly, yes, yes. The execution wasn't perfect, but it was innovative. Below the tremendous tater, there was even a modest, pragmatic slogan. Idaho potatoes. Today, every state's got a marketing slogan. Hawaii is the Aloha State, Missouri is the Show Me State.
注册号码直接用绿色字样印在这个凹凸不平的棕色土豆顶部。我要说它看起来几乎带有粪便的性质。确实如此。尤其是形状，是的，是的。制作过程并不完美，但它很有创新性。在这块巨大的土豆下方，甚至还有一个朴素、务实的口号。爱达荷土豆。今天，每个州都有营销口号。夏威夷是阿罗哈州，密苏里州是展示州。
But Idaho was the first to put theirs on a license plate. They wanted to make sure that when people thought about Idaho, they thought potatoes. And for better or worse, the association stuck. And now it's gotten to be such a thing. I mean, coming up here in a few days at New Year's Eve, we drop a potato. What do you mean? Well, you know how the Times Square. comes floating down like that.
但爱达荷州是第一个把口号印在车牌上的州。他们想确保当人们想到爱达荷州时，就会想到土豆。不管好坏，这个联系就这么固定下来了。现在它已经成了一件大事。我的意思是，几天后的跨年夜，我们要举行掉土豆仪式。你是什么意思？嗯，你知道时代广场那个……
Well, we have a big potato that comes floating down. They've been doing it about 10 years now. The concept of slapping a tagline onto a license plate might not seem like a big deal, but it turns out this idea would end up having outsized consequences and not just for Idaho. We're talking legislative clashes, multiple Supreme Court cases, and even jail time.
嗯，我们有一个大土豆落下来。他们已经搞了大约10年了。把标语贴在车牌上的概念可能看起来不算什么大事，但事实证明，这个想法最终会产生巨大的后果，而且不仅仅是对爱达荷州而言。我们在说的是立法冲突、多起最高法院案件，甚至是牢狱之灾。
Because what started in one state would soon spread, and when it did, the question of what should, go on a license plate and what shouldn't would prove surprisingly contentious. The first state-issued license plates appeared at the very beginning of the 20th century, and they served a mostly bureaucratic function. More people were buying and crashing cars every year, so state governments originally mandated plates as a way to keep track of all the nuts behind the wheel. No one was interested in sloganeering.
因为最初在一个州开始的事情很快就会蔓延开来，当它蔓延时，车牌上应该出现什么、不应该出现什么的问题被证明具有惊人的争议性。全美第一个由州发行的车牌出现在20世纪初，它们主要用于行政职能。每年都有越来越多的人买车并发生车祸，因此州政府最初强制要求使用车牌，作为追踪方向盘后面所有马大哈的一种方式。当时没有人对标语感兴趣。
But then Americans discovered the road trip. Well, the big factor with increase in automobiles was that it allowed people freedom to roam. You could go wherever you wanted. Christine Byron is a former history librarian at the Grand Rapids Public Library. She focuses on the history of tourism, and she says that the rise of the road trip in the 1920s created this huge new tourist market. Drivers needed services like gas stations and roadside motels that had to be. existed in the age of steam-powered travel.
但随后美国人发现了自驾游。嗯，汽车增多带来的大因素是它让人们获得了四处游荡的自由。你想去哪儿就去哪儿。克里斯蒂娜·拜伦是大急流城公共图书馆的前历史图书管理员。她专注于旅游史，她说20世纪20年代自驾游的兴起创造了一个巨大的全新旅游市场。司机需要加油站和路边汽车旅馆等服务，而这些在蒸汽动力旅行时代是不存在的。
Travel in east, travel in west. When you traveled by steamship or railroad, you pretty much brought what you needed with you, and your meals were served at a resort. But once the automobile came along, there was a lot more money that needed to be spent. From the state's perspective, all those new tourist dollars were up for grabs.
向东旅行，向西旅行。当你乘蒸汽船或铁路旅行时，你基本上随身携带你需要的东西，你的饭菜则在度假村里供应。但一旦汽车出现，就需要花更多的钱。从州的视角来看，所有这些新的游客美元都唾手可得。
So states started letting the world know what they had to offer. Arizona had the Grand Canyon, Minnesota, its lakes. New Mexico, its average 310 days of sunshine per year. And in this war for tourists, states promoted themselves anywhere they could. National magazines, various automobile guides, the blue guide, the green book, and of course, tons and tons of promotional brochures. But no one thought to advertise on a license plate until 1928 when Idahoans realized that their plan. plates were too valuable to waste on just a registration number. And Rick Just says once Idaho staked its starchy flag on the license plate, the rush was on. License plates became a different thing because of that potato.
因此，各州开始向世界展示他们所拥有的东西。亚利桑那州拥有大峡谷，明尼苏达州拥有其湖泊。新墨西哥州平均每年有310天阳光普照。在这场争夺游客的战争中，各州尽可能地宣传自己。全国性杂志、各种汽车指南、蓝色指南、绿色指南，当然还有成吨成吨的宣传册。但直到1928年，当爱达荷州人意识到他们的平淡车牌太珍贵了，不能只浪费在一个注册号上时，才有人想到在车牌上做广告。里克·贾斯特说，一旦爱达荷州在车牌上插上了它那含有淀粉的旗帜，热潮就开始了。因为那个土豆，车牌变成了完全不同的东西。
States spent the middle of the century transforming their plates from austere government documents into colorful boosters of tourism and industry. You could even think of them as miniature little ads that are driving, you know, all over the state and all over the country, hopefully. In 1940, Arizona stamped Grand Canyon State on its plates and never looked back. In 1950, Minnesota went with land of 10,000 lakes. Meanwhile, New Mexico actually put Sunshine State on its plates in 1932, before Florida muscled in the slogan in 1949.
在世纪中叶，各州花时间将车牌从简朴的政府文件转变为旅游业和工业的多彩宣传品。你甚至可以把它们想象成微型小广告，它们正在全国各地，希望如此，也在整个州到处行驶。1940年，亚利桑那州在车牌上印上了“大峡谷州”，并且再也没有回头。1950年，明尼苏达州选择了“万湖之州”。与此同时，新墨西哥州实际上在1932年就在车牌上印上了“阳光州”，比佛罗里达州在1949年抢占这个标语还要早。
Florida, for the record, only has an average of 237 days of sunshine for year, but whatever. Wisconsin was America's dairy land. Maine was vacation land. Other states couldn't make up their minds. Michigan's plate, for example, initially sported the phrase water wonderland in 1954. Which then evolved into winter water wonderland. Followed by Great Lakes State, Great Lakes, and Great Lakes Splendor. In 1970, Michigan's state tourism council actually adopted the slogan, the Michigan's, the almost islands of the Great Lakes.
作为记录，佛罗里达州平均每年只有237天的阳光，但管他呢。威斯康星州是美国的乳酪之乡。缅因州是度假之乡。其他州则无法下定决心。例如，密歇根州的车牌最初在1954年印有“水上仙境”字样。后来演变成“冬水仙境”。接着是“五大湖州”、“五大湖”和“五大湖风光”。1970年，密歇根州旅游委员会实际上采用了“密歇根州，五大湖的准岛屿”这一口号。
But sadly, that plate never happened. Today, license plates like these are a national institution, and it's fun in a kitsy Americana kind of way. Each state is earnestly trying to put its best foot forward. So what could possibly be wrong here? It turns out quite a bit. Because as fun as some of these plates might have been, at half a square foot, a license plate is a small canvas. And when you have to pick one symbol to represent an entire state, you are not going to please everyone. And this has caused trouble from the get-go.
但遗憾的是，那块车牌从未真正出现过。今天，像这样的车牌已经成为一种国家制度，并且以一种俗气的美国风情让人感到有趣。每个州都在真诚地展现自己最好的一面。那么这里究竟会有什么问题呢？事实证明，问题还真不少。因为不管其中一些车牌有多有趣，在半平方英尺的面积上，车牌只是一块小画布。当你要挑选一个符号来代表整个州时，你不可能取悦所有人。这从一开始就惹出了麻烦。
In 1928, when Idaho unleashed the potato plates, it didn't go over all that well. People detested those license plates. Lots of Idahoans, it turned out, resented being associated with the state's cash crop. Particularly people from northern Idaho, because they don't grow potatoes up there. Really, it's a kind of a southeastern Idaho thing. Newspaper editorials called it an embarrassment. One headline actually read, Why bring that up?
1928年，当爱达荷州推出土豆车牌时，情况并不太妙。人们厌恶那些车牌。事实证明，许多爱达荷州人反感与该州的经济作物联系在一起。特别是来自爱达荷州北部的人，因为他们那里不种土豆。真的，这更像是爱达荷州东南部的事情。报纸社论称其为一种尴尬。一个头条新闻甚至写道：“为什么要提起这个？”
And probably it's a good thing that they just dropped the idea entirely and went back to numbers in 1929. No motto, no graphics, and certainly no potatoes. And license plate quarrels weren't unique to Idaho. Florida had to dump one of its plate designs after residents complained that the grapefruit with a stem attached looked more like a bomb. Massachusetts, meanwhile, tried to put a codfish right next to its state's name, only to be blamed by fishermen for a poor catch that year because the fish on the plate was swimming away from the word Massachusetts. These dustups over license plate design can seem like, well, small potatoes.
可能他们完全放弃这个想法并在1929年改回纯数字是一件好事。没有座右铭，没有图形，当然也没有土豆。而且车牌争端并非爱达荷州独有。佛罗里达州不得不废弃其中一款车牌设计，因为居民抱怨带柄的葡萄看起来更像一颗炸弹。与此同时，马萨诸塞州试图在州名旁边放一条鳕鱼，结果当年却遭到渔民的指责，称其导致当年的渔获量不佳，因为车牌上的鱼正在游离“马萨诸塞”这个词。这些围绕车牌设计的争执看起来像是……嗯，小菜一碟。
But the fight over licensed plates was about to be taken to the next level, thanks to a politician named Meljum Thompson. In this critical battle for the survival of America, we shall not tolerate a no-win settlement. Thompson was a titan of New Hampshire politics in the 1970s. He served three terms as governor, and he was a conservative firebrand who hated Democrats. We must drive from the seats of power in the White House, Congress, and the State Department, all of the foul brood of commie lovers. Thompson had a lot of unorthodox ideas, including wanting to arm the New Hampshire National Guard with nuclear weapons.
但由于一位名叫梅尔德里姆·汤普森的政治家，围绕车牌的斗争即将被推向一个新的高度。在这场关乎美国生存的关键战役中，我们绝不容忍没有赢家的妥协。汤普森是20世纪70年代新罕布什尔州政坛的泰斗。他担任过三届州长，是一个痛恨民主党的保守派狂热分子。我们必须把白宫、国会和国务院权力宝座上所有那些共产主义爱者的肮脏后代全部赶下台。汤普森有很多非传统的想法，包括希望用核武器武装新罕布什尔州国民警卫队。
And he was obsessed with freedom. Here's Thompson's dorky campaign song. Live for your die, don't let the freedom pass you by, stand up proud and strong, and lead this country on. Live for your die, of course, is New Hampshire's fiery state motto. It was coined by a revolutionary war vet. And Thompson loved it so much that before he became governor, he worked with allies in the state legislature to get it slapped on every car in the state. And I don't know of any more prominent place to carry a message. then write on the license plate.
而且他对自由着迷。这是汤普森古怪的竞选歌曲。为自由而生或去死，不要让自由从你身边溜走，昂首挺胸，引领这个国家前进。为自由而生或去死，当然是新罕布什尔州激昂的州座右铭。它是由一位独立战争老兵创造的。汤普森非常喜欢它，以至于在成为州长之前，他与州议会的盟友合作，将其印在了州内每一辆汽车上。而且我不知道还有什么地方比直接在车牌上更能传递信息了。
That's the best billboard of all. In 1971, the slogan on the state's license plate changed from scenic New Hampshire to live free or die. But not everyone embraced the state's message. That's ridiculous. At 88 years old, George Maynard still gets heated about the New Hampshire license plate. And for good reason, it changed the. course of his life. George grew up in Rhode Island. He married a woman, Maxine, who he'd actually met in junior high. They settled into a pretty typical family life. They had kids. George got a job
那是最好的巨幅广告。1971年，该州车牌上的标语从“风景优美的新罕布什尔”改为“不自由，毋宁死”。但并非所有人都接受该州的信息。这太荒谬了。88岁的乔治·梅纳德谈起新罕布什尔州车牌时依然激愤不已。这是有充分理由的，它改变了。他的人生轨迹。乔治在罗德岛长大。他娶了一位名叫玛克辛的女子，两人其实在初中时就认识了。他们过上了相当典型的家庭生活。他们有了孩子。乔治找到了一份工作……
as a newspaper printer. And then something happened, like really abruptly. In 1956, four years after I got married, the witnesses came to my house. They told me that God had a name and his name was Jehovah. George and his family joined the Jehovah's Witnesses. And by 1972, they had moved to Claremont, New Hampshire. That's where the trouble started. Every day, George would hop in his car and drive to work at the local printing press, with his New Hampshire license plates screaming, in all caps, live, free or die. And this really graded on George, because he didn't share Meldron Thompson's belief of freedom over everything.
作为一名报纸印刷工。然后发生了一件事，非常突然。1956年，在我结婚四年后，见证人来到了我家。他们告诉我上帝有个名字，他的名字叫耶和华。乔治和他的家人加入了耶和华见证人。到1972年，他们搬到了新罕布什尔州的克莱蒙特。麻烦就是从那里开始的。每天，乔治都会跳上车去当地的印刷厂上班，车上挂着的新罕布什尔州车牌用全部大写字母尖叫着“不自由，毋宁死”。这让乔治非常抓狂，因为他并不认同梅尔德里姆·汤普森关于自由高于一切的信念。
As a Jehovah's Witness, George actually believed that God-given life was more important than freedom. Oh, that's right. Definitely. And the real existence of life is very precious. Life is a gift. And we appreciate it very much. George didn't want the government telling him what to die for. So then one day I decided, you know, if it's offensive, why should be forced to support something that's offensive? So I carved it up with writ tape. And when he erased the state motto, George marched to the front lines of the license plate wars. covering up the slogan was a violation of state law,
作为一名耶和华见证人，乔治实际上认为上帝赋予的生命比自由更重要。哦，没错。绝对的。而且生命真实的存在是非常宝贵的。生命是一份礼物。我们非常感激它。乔治不想让政府告诉他为什么去死。所以有一天我决定，你知道的，如果它具有冒犯性，为什么我要被迫支持某种具有冒犯性的东西呢？于是我用红色胶带把它贴了起来。当他抹去州座右铭时，乔治走到了车牌战争的最前线。掩盖标语违反了州法。
but a few weeks went by and not much happened. Until one day, George and Maxine were shopping. They left the store, they got to their car in the parking lot, and they saw a police officer writing them a ticket. George told me he'd been expecting this for a while. He didn't actually feel scared or surprised. Well, I was happy. You were happy?
但几个星期过去了，并没有发生什么大事。直到有一天，乔治和玛克辛在购物。他们离开商店，走到停车场他们的车前，看到一个警察正在给他们开罚单。乔治告诉我，他预料到会有这一天已经有一段时间了。他其实并不感到害怕或惊讶。嗯，我很高兴。你很高兴？
Yeah, because I was expressing my belief, my rejection of something. George refused to pay the $25 ticket, and of course, I kept the tape on, I did it again. The tickets piled up until his consistent refusal to pay landed him in court. And the judge put him away for 15 days. And so if you don't want to live free or die, you'll go to jail in New Hampshire. Two weeks may not seem like hard time, but the sentence had a huge impact on George's life.
是的，因为我在表达我的信念，表达我对某种东西的拒绝。乔治拒绝支付25美元的罚单，当然，我一直贴着胶带，我又做了一次。罚单堆积如山，直到他持续拒绝付款把他送上了法庭。法官判了他15天监禁。所以如果你不想“不自由，毋宁死”，你在新罕布什尔州就会进监狱。两周时间可能看起来不算漫长的铁窗生涯，但这次判决对乔治的生活产生了巨大影响。
When he didn't show up for work, he got fired. And he was embarrassed that his kids had to see him hauled away. Things were tough for the Maynards. But George still wasn't done fighting. With the help of the American Civil Liberties Union, he filed suit in New Hampshire, claiming the state's law prohibiting the altering of license plates was unconstitutional. And the state court agreed. But Meldrim, Live Free or Die, Thompson, had become governor by then.
当他没有去上班时，他被解雇了。而且他感到尴尬的是，他的孩子们不得不看着他被带走。梅纳德一家的日子很艰难。但乔治还没有停止抗争。在美国公民自由联盟的帮助下，他在新罕布什尔州提起诉讼，称该州禁止修改车牌的法律违宪。州法院表示同意。但梅尔德里姆·“不自由，毋宁死”·汤普森到那时已经成了州长。
And Thompson was not inclined to extend George the freedom to cover up his beloved motto. So Thompson appealed the case. We'll hear arguments next in... All the way to the U.S. Supreme Court. 751453, bully against Maynard. The license plates collided with the First Amendment before the High Court in November of 1976.
汤普森并不打算赋予乔治掩盖他喜爱的座右铭的自由。于是汤普森对该案提起了上诉。我们接下来将听取……一路打到了美国最高法院。751453，博利诉梅纳德案。1976年11月，车牌在最高法院与第一修正案发生了碰撞。
During oral arguments, George Maynard's lawyer claimed that in covering up, live-free or die, George was just exercising his freedom of expression. License plates are displayed on people's private vehicles. He argued the government can't just hijack that space and force people to express a certain viewpoint. And it's our position that the state lacks the power to require its citizens to bear this sort of motto.
在口头辩论期间，乔治·梅纳德的律师声称，在掩盖“不自由，毋宁死”时，乔治只是在行使其言论自由。车牌展示在人们的私家车上。他辩称，政府不能仅仅劫持这个空间并强迫人们表达某种观点。我们的立场是，州政府没有权力要求其公民背负这种座右铭。
I think that if the court were to uphold this sort of thing, then the state could require all citizens to wear a pin or an armband. Or they could require you to have a plaque on your door next to your address saying live free or die. New Hampshire countered with, what's the big deal? Just because it's on the license plate doesn't mean every driver believes in it. And sometimes it seemed like the court was buying it, like Justice Thurgood. The first time I noticed Martel was after this case was filed. I had never paid any attention to it.
我认为，如果法院维持这种做法，那么州政府就可以要求所有公民佩戴徽章或臂章。或者他们可以要求你在门上紧挨着地址的地方挂一块牌子，上面写着“不自由，毋宁死”。新罕布什尔州反驳说，这有什么大不了的？仅仅因为它在车牌上，并不意味着每个司机都信仰它。有时看起来法院接受了这种说法，就像大法官瑟古德……我注意到马特尔是在这个案子提起之后。我从来没有注意过它。
I noticed New Hampshire license. I said, well, it's about New Hampshire. But I didn't live or die about it. Well, most people in New Hampshire don't either. They accept it. So what was it? Was a license plate a declaration of the state's ideology or just a thing that says nothing at all
我注意到了新罕布什尔州的车牌。我说，嗯，这是关于新罕布什尔州的。但我并没有为此去死。好吧，新罕布什尔州的大多数人也没有。他们接受了它。那么它究竟是什么？车牌是该州意识形态的宣言，还是只是一件什么也没说的东西……
since everybody had one? George couldn't make it to D.C. for the ruling. He actually found out the same way as everyone else. From CBS News headquarters in New York, this is the CBS Evening News with Walter Cronkite. The Supreme Court ruled today that drivers may not be compelled to... Cronkite came on the news and says that the Supreme Court rule is our favor
既然每个人都有一块？乔治没能去华盛顿特区听取裁决。他其实和所有人一样，是通过相同的方式得知结果的。来自纽约的CBS新闻总部，这是沃尔特·克朗凯特主持的CBS晚间新闻。最高法院今天裁定，司机不能被强迫……克朗凯特在新闻中说，最高法院裁决对我们有利……
that you can tape over the state bottles, and so that was nice. The court, in effect, gave them permission to tape over the offensive words. the court got it right in the Maynard case. Caroline Mala Corbin is a First Amendment scholar at the University of Miami. She says the court's 6-3 decision hinged on a concept called compelled speech. The First Amendment protects both your right to speak, so it protects you against government censorship. But the free speech clause also protects your right not to speak. So it protects you against the government forcing you to say an ideological
你可以用胶带把州的座右铭贴上，所以这挺好的。法院实际上允许他们用胶带盖住那些冒犯性的字眼。法院在梅纳德案中做出了正确的判决。卡罗琳·马拉·科宾是迈阿密大学的第一修正案学者。她说，法院6比3的裁决取决于一个名为“被迫言论”的概念。第一修正案既保护你说话的权利，从而保护你免受政府审查。但言论自由条款也保护你不说话的权利。因此它保护你免受政府强迫你说出某种意识形态的……
message that you disagree with. And that was what the problem was here. They were trying to force you to say something that you don't want to say and you don't want to live by. In George's homemade solution, that strip of red tape, it actually held up under the weight of the First Amendment. And so that's my way of expressing my free speech. At this point, it might seem like George Maynard's case solved the license plate problem.
与你意见相左的信息。这就是这里的问题所在。他们试图强迫你说出你不想说的话，也不想按照那种方式生活。而乔治自制的解决方案——那条红胶带，实际上经受住了第一修正案分量的考验。所以这就是我表达言论自由的方式。在这一点上，看起来乔治·梅纳德的案子解决了车牌问题。
Today, if you live in, say, New Jersey and object to the notion that you live in the garden state, well, you can cover that sucker up. Your car is not a government billboard on wheels. But it turns out the constitutional battle over license plates is not over, because after all that was settled, a new problem showed up. Specialty plates. You've seen these. Unlike vanity plates where drivers choose their own numbers and letters, specialty plates sport alternate designs with their own logos and slogans. They're usually put out in collaboration with the government by a non-governmental organization. When drivers choose a specialty plate, they pay a little extra, and those proceeds get split between their chosen group and the State Department of Motor Vehicles.
今天，如果你住在诸如新泽西州这样的地方，并且反对你住在花园州的观念，嗯，你可以把那个讨厌的东西盖起来。你的汽车不是轮子上的政府巨幅广告。但事实证明，关于车牌的宪法斗争并没有结束，因为在这一切尘埃落定之后，一个新问题出现了。特色车牌。你见过这些。与车主自己选择数字和字母的个性化车牌不同，特色车牌采用具有自己徽标和标语的替代设计。它们通常由非政府组织与政府合作推出。当车主选择特色车牌时，他们会支付额外的一点费用，而这些收益会在他们选择的团体和州机动车辆部之间进行分配。
So, for example, in my family, we have a Save the Manatees license plate. That's a specialty license plate that the state of Florida offers that we paid extra money to purchase. Why did you choose the Manatee plate? What are ridiculous questions we want to save a manatee naturally. Specialty plates are easy money. A lot of states will issue one to almost any nonprofit, as long as enough people are interested. But the problem with an open-door policy is you might not like who comes inside.
所以，例如，在我们家里，我们有一块“拯救海牛”车牌。那是佛罗里达州提供的一款特色车牌，我们花额外的钱购买了它。你为什么选择海牛车牌？多么荒谬的问题，我们当然想要拯救海牛。特色车牌是轻而易举的钱。只要有足够多的人感兴趣，许多州几乎会向任何非营利组织发行这种车牌。但敞开大门政策的问题在于，你可能不会喜欢进来的人。
And a decade ago, the state of Texas learned that the hard way. I'm now calling the meeting for November 10, 2011, at the board of the Texas Department of Motor Vehicles to Order. Usually public hearings for the DMV are dull, bureaucracuse. Democratic affairs, poorly attended. But in 2011, the board of the Texas DMV held a standing room-only hearing. So we're going to move to agenda item 5A, which is the approval of specialty license plate. The DMV board votes on proposed designs for specialty plates. They generally approve the designs with very little fanfare or scrutiny. But this one was different.
十年前，德克萨斯州用惨痛的代价学到了这一点。我现在宣布2011年11月10日德克萨斯州机动车辆部董事会会议开幕。通常机动车辆部的公开听证会都是沉闷的、满口官腔的事务，民主化且出席人数寥寥。但在2011年，德克萨斯州机动车辆部董事会举行了一场座无虚席的听证会。所以我们要转到议程项目5A，即批准特色车牌。机动车辆部董事会对提议的特色车牌设计进行投票。他们通常以极少的热烈讨论或审查来批准设计。但这一个不同。
The sons of Confederate veterans wanted Texas to issue a license plate featuring the Confederate Battleflag, and a lot of people weren't happy about it. Dozens of community leaders showed up to testify. Good morning. Thank you very much for letting me come. That voice you're hearing is Sanfronia Thompson. She's a Texas State House representative and a black woman born in 1939.
邦联老兵后代希望德州发行印有邦联战旗的车牌，很多人对此感到不满。数十名社区领袖到场作证。早上好。非常感谢你们让我来。你听到的那个声音是桑弗尼亚·汤普森。她是德克萨斯州众议院议员，也是一位出生于1939年的黑人女性。
There was a time that I could not even come on the grounds of the capital because I was black. And it's very difficult to be able to see these symbols because they bring back memories. And to me, it's like sticking poop in the face of black people every day to see them. That's how repulsive it is. We have folks who say, well, I'm offended by the SCV plate. And my response is, and your point?
曾几何时，我甚至不能踏上国会大厦的土地，因为我是黑人。要看到这些符号是非常困难的，因为它们会勾起回忆。对我来说，看着它们就像每天把大便糊在黑人脸上一样。它是如此令人反感。我们有些人说，嗯，我被邦联老兵车牌冒犯了。我的回应是，所以呢？
In favor of the Confederate flag plates was Jerry Patterson. He's the commissioner of the Texas Land Office and a member of the sons of Confederate veterans. Nolan has a right to go. through life to be unoffended. Patterson made a First Amendment argument. He thought that if enough people like him wanted a specialty plate related to Texas history, then the state shouldn't be allowed to prevent him from having it.
赞成邦联旗帜车牌的是杰里·帕特森。他是德克萨斯州土地局局长，也是邦联老兵后代的成员。没有人有权在生活中不受冒犯。帕特森提出了第一修正案的论点。他认为，如果像他这样有足够多的人想要一块与德州历史相关的特色车牌，那么就不应该阻止他拥有它。
There's also some folks who suggested, well, now, if you want to do that, have it a Mexican flag plate. And I say, bring it on. And if that plate offended anyone? My response to them is, well, get a grip. It's going to happen, as it should be. After two hours of tense testimony, the board held its vote.
还有一些人建议，好吧，如果你想这么做，那就搞个墨西哥国旗车牌。我说，放马过来吧。如果那块车牌冒犯了任何人？我对他们的回应是，振作点吧。这将会发生，本该如此。经过两个小时紧张的作证，董事会进行了投票。
All those in favor of denying the plate, please raise your right hand. All is opposed. Motion carries unanimously. The plate is denied. There would not be a Texas license plate featuring a Confederate flag. But then the sons of Confederate veterans sued. Arguing that the state had violated their free speech rights by a targeting speech that they did not like.
所有赞成拒绝该车牌的人，请举起你们的右手。所有反对的。动议一致通过。该车牌被拒绝。德克萨斯州不会出现印有邦联旗帜的车牌。但随后邦联老兵后代起诉了。辩称该州通过针对他们不喜欢的言论，侵犯了他们的言论自由权。
Remember, Texas had an open-door policy on specialty plates, which meant that they weren't normally in the business of picking sides. So the state really was singling out the sons of Confederate veterans when it denied their plate. And once again, there was a lot at stake here. George Maynard's Live for Your Die case had established that you could reject the state's messaging if it didn't suit you. But was it okay for the state to reject your message on a state-few? issued license plate.
记住，德克萨斯州对特色车牌实行敞开大门政策，这意味着他们通常不参与挑边站。因此，当该州拒绝邦联老兵后代的车牌时，确实是在单挑他们。这一次，同样有很多利益攸关。乔治·梅纳德的“不自由，毋宁死”案已经确立了如果你不喜欢该州的信息，你可以拒绝它。但州政府拒绝你在州发行的车牌上的信息，这可以吗？
We'll hear argument first this morning in case 14144. So in 2015, license plates were back in the Supreme Court. John Walker versus the Texas Division of the Sons of Confederate Veterans. This was a really close decision, a 5-4 split. But the court's majority sided with Texas. The state could deny the Confederate flag plates. The court acknowledged Jerry Patterson's right to display symbols, even abhorrent ones, on say a bumper sticker.
我们今天首先听取14144号案件的辩论。因此，在2015年，车牌再次回到了最高法院。约翰·沃克诉德克萨斯州邦联老兵后代分会案。这是一场非常势均力敌的裁决，5比4的分裂。但法院多数派站在了德克萨斯州一边。该州可以拒绝邦联旗帜车牌。法院承认杰里·帕特森展示符号的权利，甚至是令人厌恶的符号，比如在车贴上。
but they said that right does not extend to license plates. Because the Supreme Court held that specialty license plates were government speech. And the government's right to speak is also protected. Justice Stephen Breyer, in his opinion, actually pointed to a kind of legal symmetry with the live-free or die case. Just like a state can't force an individual to display a message. So the sons of Confederate veterans cannot force Texas to convey on license plates, a message with which the state does not agree. Ultimately, the Supreme Court's decision in George Maynard's case didn't resolve all the issues
但他们表示，这种权利不适用于车牌。因为最高法院认为特色车牌属于政府言论。政府说话的权利同样受到保护。大法官斯蒂芬·布雷耶在他的意见中，实际上指出了与“不自由，毋宁死”案的一种法律对称性。正如一个州不能强迫个人展示某个信息一样。因此，邦联老兵后代也不能强迫德克萨斯州在车牌上传递该州不同意的信息。归根结底，最高法院对乔治·梅纳德案的裁决并没有解决围绕车牌的所有问题……
around license plates, and neither will the Texas decision. Caroline Mala Corbin thinks license plates will always be a contested space, a government-issued document displayed on a private vehicle. It's as if a license plate is a kind of bullhorn, only instead of taking turns speaking, You have both the government and private individuals shouting into the bullhorn. The problem is they're both speaking. And perhaps that's why this little hunk of metal has so often become an ideological battleground, a place for governments and citizens to clash over the identity of an entire state
德克萨斯州的裁决也不会。卡罗琳·马拉·科宾认为车牌将永远是一个充满争议的空间，一份展示在私家车上的由政府发行的文件。这就好像车牌是一种扩音器，只是不是轮流说话，而是政府和私人都在对着扩音器大喊大叫。问题在于他们都在说话。也许这就是为什么这小块金属经常成为意识形态战场的原因，这是一个政府和公民为了整个州的身份认同而发生冲突的地方……
in its attempt to reduce it to a slogan and symbol speeding down the highway. And those debates are still playing out. The Supreme Court ruling empowered Texas to keep the Confederate flag off its license plates, but it also empowered states to make the opposite choice, and at least six have. If you live in South Carolina, Mississippi, Alabama, Louisiana, Georgia, or Tennessee, you can go to your local DMV today and register your car with a state-issued specialty plate bearing a Confederate battle flag. In a couple of those states, Tennessee and South Carolina, lawmakers have actually introduced bills that would ban the flag from specialty plates.
并在试图将其简化为在高速公路上飞驰的标语和符号。这些争论仍在继续。最高法院的裁决授权德克萨斯州将邦联旗帜排除在车牌之外，但也授权各州做出相反的选择，至少有六个州这样做了。如果你住在南卡罗来纳州、密西西比州、阿拉巴马州、路易斯安那州、佐治亚州或田纳西州，你今天就可以去当地的机动车辆部，用印有邦联战旗的州发行特色车牌来注册你的汽车。在其中的几个州，田纳西州和南卡罗来纳州，议员们实际上已经提出了法案，禁止在特色车牌上使用该旗帜。
But so far, neither Bill has gotten a vote. And in Idaho, although it might not ever make it to the U.S. Supreme Court, the state's official license plate still raises eyebrows. And, you know, I wish we would change it. And some folks, like Rick Just, are still less than happy about it. I don't think that anybody really thinks it's a bad, evil thing or anything. But, you know, I'm just tired of it. There is no longer a lumpy brown spud on the license plate, but the motto still reads,
但到目前为止，两项法案都未获得投票通过。在爱达荷州，尽管它可能永远不会闹到美国最高法院，但该州的官方车牌仍然令人侧目。而且，你知道，我希望我们能换掉它。有些人，比如里克·贾斯特，对此仍然很不满意。我不认为真的有人认为这是一件坏事、邪恶的事情之类的。但是，你知道，我只是厌倦了它。车牌上已经没有了那块凹凸不平的棕色土豆，但座右铭依然写着……
famous potatoes. When we come back, reporter Daniel Ackerman takes us into the subculture of license plate collectors. You knew they existed. They do exist. Stay with us. So I'm here with Daniel Ackerman. Hey, Dan. Hey, Roman.
著名土豆。当我们回来时，记者丹尼尔·阿克曼将带我们走进车牌收藏家的亚文化。你知道它们存在的。它们确实存在。请继续收听。所以我在这里和丹尼尔·阿克曼在一起。嘿，丹。嘿，罗曼。
So I know you talked to some really passionate license plate collectors for this story that we ended up cutting out, but can you tell us more about them? Yeah, so amateur collectors are really the keepers. of this history. There's not like a Smithsonian Museum of the American license plate or anything like that. It's just kind of like archived in the basement and attics around the country. Yeah, exactly. And one of those archivists is Stuart Berg. I recently visited Stewart here in Boston to check out his collection because he's been collecting since he was a kid in the 70s. And he said he inherited his first plates from his grandfather. My grandfather had a lot of really cool old cars and there were 21 plates hanging in his garage.
我知道你为这个故事采访了一些非常热情的车牌收藏家，这些内容我们最终剪掉了，但你能跟我们多讲讲他们吗？是的，所以业余收藏者真的是这段历史的守护者。没有什么美国车牌史密森尼博物馆之类的地方。它只是有点像被归档在全国各地的地下室和阁楼里。是的，完全正确。其中一位档案管理员就是斯图尔特·伯格。我最近在波士顿拜访了斯图尔特，查看了他的收藏，因为他从70年代还是个孩子的时候就开始收藏了。他说他的第一块车牌是从他祖父那里继承的。我祖父有很多非常酷的老爷车，他的车库里挂着21块车牌。
And at one point, I took them all down, and I actually have every one of those plates except one today. And the one that I got rid of, I'm dying to get back. So like every true collector, his collection is perpetually one item short. Yeah. Although he has certainly made up for that missing plate in terms of volume. Because at one point, he told me his plate collection topped 100,000. Whoa. How do you even accumulate that many plates?
有一段时间，我把它们全都取下来了，实际上除了一个之外，我今天拥有所有那些车牌。而我处理掉的那个，我做梦都想找回来。就像每个真正的收藏家一样，他的收藏永远缺一件。是的。尽管他在数量上肯定弥补了那块丢失的车牌。因为有一次他告诉我，他的车牌收藏超过了10万块。哇。你怎么能收集到那么多车牌？
Roman, I wanted to know that too, but Stuart was pretty reluctant to give up his sources. Oh, I see. But when it was at its height, his plate collection, it was so thorough that, you know, in the classic car world, someone who wanted an accurate vintage plate to go with their vintage car, they would just call up Stewart. And I wanted every year that if somebody said, hey, I need a three-digit plate from my Buick from 1931. can you can you get me one and i'd have it so when i went to visit stewart we sat out on the pool deck near his condo because of covid um and he rolled out this wagon with two huge plastic tubs completely packed with plates each one was in his own little protective sleeve and he just started
罗曼，我也想知道答案，但斯图尔特很不愿透露他的来源。哦，我明白了。但在鼎盛时期，他的车牌收藏是如此全面，以至于在老爷车世界里，想要一块精准的老爷车年代车牌来搭配他们老爷车的人，只需给斯图尔特打个电话。我想要每一年都有，如果有人说，嘿，我需要一块我1931年别克汽车的三位数车牌，你能帮我弄到一块吗？我就会有。所以当我去看望斯图尔特时，因为疫情，我们坐在他公寓附近的泳池甲板上，他推出一个推车，上面放着两个塞满车牌的巨大塑料桶。每一个都放在它自己的小保护套里，然后他开始……
pulling out and showing me some of his favorites starting with some of the earliest state issued license plates which were from the first decade at the 1900s and so what were those like they were really fancy. To me, they actually looked more like fine china than vehicle tags. And that's because they were literally made of porcelain. Well, that seems a little too fragile to go on a car. How does that work? Yeah, well, he was actually pretty proud that he had some without any like chips or dings in them. But, you know, keep in mind at that time, only really rich people owned cars. Like, they weren't even that reliable as a mode of transport, but they were definitely a status symbol. And the license plates kind of played along. There were these smooth, co-bolemen
掏出来向我展示他的一些最爱，首先是一些最早由州发行的车牌，它们来自20世纪的第一个十年。那么那些是什么样的呢？它们非常精美。对我来说，它们其实看起来更像精美的瓷器而不是汽车标签。那是因为它们真的是用瓷器制作的。嗯，这听起来太脆弱了，不能装在车上。这怎么行？是的，好吧，他其实挺自豪的，因为他有一些上面没有任何缺口或磕碰的车牌。但是，你要记住，在那个时候，只有真正有钱的人才拥有汽车。它们作为交通工具甚至都不是那么可靠，但它们绝对是身份的象征。而车牌也顺应了这一点。它们是光滑的、鹅卵石蓝……
blue with bold white numbering. And I can actually show you one if you'd like to see it. Here's a 1909 number five. Feel how heavy that is? Oh, yeah. It was registered to a James P. Stearns, 31 Pleasant Street and Brookline Mass for a three-horspower Pope Electric. A Pope Electric? What's a Pope Electric?
配上醒目的白色编号。如果你想看的话，我实际上可以给你展示一个。这是一个1909年的五号。感觉一下有多重？哦，是的。它注册给詹姆斯·P·斯特恩斯，地址是布鲁克迈斯州普莱ザ特街31号，用于一辆三马力的波普电动汽车。波普电动汽车？什么是波普电动汽车？
It's an electric car. Oh, okay. There you go. So, I mean, this is before combustion took over. They were still experimenting with all these different. types of engines. That's how new the automobile was at the time. Oh, yeah. So I don't know if you caught that, but the license plate number was just five, as in it was Massachusetts' fifth state license plate. That is remarkable. I mean, having, you know, license plate number five has got to confer some bragging rights in the
这是一辆电动汽车。哦，好吧。原来如此。所以，我的意思是，这是在内燃机接管之前。他们当时还在试验所有这些不同类型的发动机。当时汽车是多么新颖的东西。哦，是的。所以不知道你有没有注意到，车牌号仅仅是五，就好像它是马萨诸塞州的第五块州车牌一样。这太 remarquable 了。我的意思是，拥有……你知道的，五号车牌在车牌收藏界一定能带来一些吹牛的资本。
license plate collection community. Right. It absolutely does. And at the time, it also conferred bragging rights to the owner, like James P. Stearns, he was a bank president. So he was, you know, kind of high society at time. And Stuart also had First Lady Francis Cleveland's license plate, married to President Grover Cleveland, and she was number 44. 44 is pretty good. But I dig it that the era of fancy porcelain plates with low numbers didn't last all that long. No, and that's thanks mainly to Henry Ford and his Model T. Cars got way more affordable in the 19-teens. And in the first quarter of the century, the number of registered cars in the U.S. jumped from 8,000 to more than 18 million.
对。绝对能。在当时，它也为车主带来了吹牛的资本，比如詹姆斯·P·斯特恩斯，他是一位银行行长。所以他当时算是上流社会的人。斯图尔特还拥有第一夫人弗朗西斯·克利夫兰的车牌，她嫁给了格罗弗·克利夫兰总统，她是第44号。44号相当不错。但我发现带有低编号的精美瓷器车牌时代并没有持续多久。没有，这主要归功于亨利·福特和他的T型车。在2010年代，汽车变得更加实惠。在本世纪的头二十五年里，美国注册汽车的数量从8,000辆跃升至超过1,800万辆。
So as early as 1916, Massachusetts was stamping their plates out of tin, which was way cheaper. So these mass-produced metal plates, they hit the scene. And that's when, you know, license plates, as we talk about in the story, basically become billboards. Right. They become this space where states can play around with graphics and slogans. And Stewart has thousands of examples. So during our interview, he was, you know, pulling out plate after plate after plate. Like, I would try to ask him a question and he would, you know, throw off a one-word answer,
因此，早在1916年，马萨诸塞州就用锡冲压他们的车牌了，这便宜得多。于是这些大规模生产的金属车牌登场了。就在那时，正如我们在故事中讨论的那样，车牌基本上变成了广告牌。对。它们成了各州可以用来试验图形和标语的空间。斯图尔特有成千上万的例子。所以在我们的采访中，他一直在抽出一块又一块又一块的车牌。比如，我试图问他一个问题，而他会抛出一个字的回答……
but already be pulling out the next graphic plate to show me. This is a golden jubilee from the state of Washington from 1939. The 36 Wyoming was the first year of the Bucking Bronco. Mount Rushmore in 1952 was on the plate. There was the first year of the state-shaped plate in Tennessee. South Carolina in 1930. They're the iodine state. where they like produce iodine?
但已经在抽出下一块图形车牌展示给我看了。这是华盛顿州1939年的金禧纪念车牌。36年的怀俄明州是腾跃野马的第一年。1952年的拉什莫尔山在车牌上。那是田纳西州出现州形车牌的第一年。1930年的南卡罗来纳州。他们是碘州。他们喜欢生产碘吗？
Yeah, here's the New York World's Fair. No real graphics, but it does have a lot of words on it. Wow. It's kind of fun to hear all the experimentation that was going on. Like the Tennessee plate was shaped like Tennessee. That's pretty cool. Yeah, he said that one was actually pretty tough to mount on people's cars. I bet.
是的，这里是纽约世博会。没有真正的图形，但上面确实有很多字。哇。听到所有正在进行的试验感觉很有趣。比如田纳西州的形状就像田纳西州。那真是太酷了。是的，他说那块车牌实际上很难安装在人们的汽车上。我敢说。
Yeah, but you know, that experimentation really exploded in the 1970s when State started putting a reflective coating on the license plates. And that basically let them print really, detailed graphics rather than having to like emboss the shapes into the metal. So design's got really busy. And I think that is perhaps best exemplified by the plates that Illinois recently introduced just back in 2017. So let's pull that one up. Oh yeah. Okay. So there's a lot going on here. Yeah. It has the light blue and red of the Chicago flag, which I like. That looks like the top of the state house, I'm assuming. And I know a wind.
是的，但你知道，这种试验在20世纪70年代真正爆发了，当时各州开始在车牌上涂反光涂层。这基本上让他们能够打印非常详细的图形，而不必把形状压印到金属中。所以设计变得非常繁琐。我认为这或许可以由伊利诺伊州在2017年刚刚推出的车牌最好地体现出来。所以让我们调出那一个。哦，是的。好的。这里有很多内容。是的。它有芝加哥市旗的浅蓝色和红色，我挺喜欢的。看起来像是州议会大厦的顶部，我猜。我知道风。
Min Mill. Yeah, shout out to rural Illinois. Yeah, because right next to that is the Chicago skyline. And then, of course, at the very far left edge is half a face of Abraham Lincoln. Right. So there's not even enough room for him. He's like split right down the nose. And it has land of Lincoln, of course, which is their motto. What's kind of interesting about this is like, this is kind of the opposite of the Idaho potato problem that we talked about in the piece. I mean, this is not the whole state boiled down into one thing. This is the whole state boiled down into way too many things to put on a license plate. Right. And, you know, it's not pretty because it's not like the canvas gets any bigger.
明米尔。是的，向伊利诺伊州农村致敬。是的，因为紧挨着它的是芝加哥的天际线。当然，最左边边缘还有亚伯拉罕·林肯的一半脸。没错。所以甚至连他的位置都不够。他就像是从鼻子正中间被劈开一样。当然，上面还有“林肯的土地”，这是他们的座右铭。关于这个有点意思的是，这有点像我们在节目中讨论过的爱达荷州土豆问题的对立面。我的意思是，这不是把整个州浓缩成一件事。这是把整个州浓缩成太多东西，根本没法塞进一个车牌里。对吧，而且，你知道，这并不好看，因为画布并没有变大。
It's still just this half a square foot and you're cramming ever more onto it. And so what do, you know, people like Stewart, you know, license plate collectors make of, you know, this kind of graphical onslaught. Like, what do they think of this as compared to the old plates? Yeah, I mean, most collectors I talk to expressed a preference for those older plates with the simple, sleek design. But a lot of them also just take the whole thing in stride, because to guys like Stuart, the more the merrier, right? Do you think license plate design has gotten, like, too busy and complicated? No, I don't. Here's a neat plate.
它仍然只有半平方英尺大小，而你却在上面塞了越来越多的东西。所以，像斯图尔特这样的人，你知道，车牌收藏家们，对这种图形的轰炸作何感想？与旧车牌相比，他们是怎么看到这一点的？是的，我的意思是，我交谈过的绝大多数收藏家都表示更喜欢那些设计简单、线条流畅的旧车牌。但他们中许多人对此也泰然处之，因为对斯图尔特这样的人来说，多多益善，对吧？你觉得车牌设计变得太繁杂复杂了吗？不，我不觉得。这里有一个很酷的车牌。
This is one of my favorites. It's the Georgia Peach. What else do I have that I can show you? More graphics just means more plates. It just means more joy for Stewart. Absolutely, yes. Just more grist for the collector's mail. Here's a Texas centennial plate from 1936.
这是我最喜欢的车牌之一。这是佐治亚州的桃子车牌。我还有什么可以展示给你的？更多的图形意味着更多的车牌。这只意味着给斯图尔特带来更多的快乐。当然，是的。这只是收藏家们的又一个谈资。这里有一个1936年的德克萨斯州百年纪念车牌。
Here's New Mexico, 1940. Great graphics on these. Utah, Center Scenic America in 1942. Ohio in 1938. There's an early graphic plate from Rhode Island. 41 Hawaii. Here's an Oklahoma plate with an F in the middle. That story originally aired
这是1940年的新墨西哥州车牌。这些车牌上的图案太棒了。1942年的犹他州“风景中心美国”车牌。1938年的俄亥俄州车牌。这是一个来自罗德岛的早期图形车牌。41年的夏威夷车牌。这是一个中间带有字母F的俄克拉荷马州车牌。这个故事最初播出
in 2021. It was produced by Daniel Ackerman, edited by Joe Rosenberg, original tech production by Bryson Barnes, remix by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Special thanks this week to a whole bunch of additional people we interviewed for this story, including Virginia Scharf, Eugene Volok, Peter Blodgett, Dan Smith, Thomas Wilson, and especially Tennessee State Representative G.A. Hardaway, who has been fighting to get the Confederate battle flag off the state's specialty plates. Kathy 2 is our executive producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barrupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashmaidon, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars.
于2021年。它由丹尼尔·阿克曼制作，乔·罗森伯格剪辑，布赖森·巴恩斯负责原始技术制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·雷尔创作。本周特别感谢我们为这个故事采访的一大批其他人，包括弗吉尼亚·沙夫、尤金·沃洛克、彼得·布洛杰特、丹·史密斯、托马斯·威尔逊，特别是田纳西州众议员G.A.哈达威，他一直在努力将邦联战斗旗从该州的特种车牌上移除。凯西2世是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、埃met·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉什迈顿、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。
The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In Beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find us on all of the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as some pictures of very fun license plates, and of course, every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99%可见标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是XM播客系列家族的一部分，现在总部设在北面六个街区外的潘多拉大楼里。位于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市区。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，还有一些非常有趣的车牌的照片，当然，还有99PI的每一期往期节目，网址是99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。